[Music]
looking for some high level gaming gear
check out face okay but of what top
scientists have determined
that wearing base gear makes you a
better gamer with at least
two percent basis for everyone no matter
what level you're at
but you need to be at least six eight to
order which i am of course
you have before december 11 to place
your order
and solidify your place in the gaming
history books so what are you waiting
for
buff up your wardrobe today and head
over to base.gg
basil i'm 68 i swear
can i order no it's crunch time
oh yeah i just discovered the most
uncomfortable show of all time
it's called smothered on tlc of course
let's start off with a cake mother and
daughter shower together
every morning okay
hey remember that game shower with your
dad simulator that was a joke just on
how bizarre it is to shower with your
parents well apparently people do it
get it parent good morning beautiful
did you sleep good i might need a coffee
you want a sip of mine
i'm married they share the same coffee
cup
oh what the speaking of weird
relationship look who showed up huh what
are you doing in here
she never comes in here all right let's
wash this together like a
functional family can you help me with
my hair you got it
[Music]
bruh what is that skin shade bruh
you're 55 and you still haven't figured
out how to put makeup on come on
she wants to leave right away why don't
you love me
brittany and i we've always lived
together and plus i'm only 19
i haven't moved away that was the case
she would probably die from separation
anxiety
and she's probably right
oh so she's tied with her mother big
deal
huh there's nothing wrong with that
isn't it why are they filming this so
you shower with your mom
yeah i shower with my mom can we film it
yes okay cool let's do it now get naked
we're filming this what the only adult
you should shower with
when you're an adult is your spouse it's
even weirder than someone film this
why what happens in that shower i don't
want to know actually
oh they have a top view camera they put
up a little gopro in there nice
is it weird or has society made it weird
huh
well i always says he can't shower with
your dad huh
maybe i missed out on uh the best part
of the day every morning
because i didn't shine god i can't even
joke about it so weird
god damn it why it was
failing stop stop this stop this
madness mom does simple things like
washing my hair or washing my body it
makes me feel
comforted
[Music]
it's one of those that it's one of those
i feel like as a parent you can have the
choice to really
make your child dependent on you like
overly dependent
but as a parent it's your job to teach a
child to be dependent on their own
and i think the fact that if you shower
maybe they don't know it's weird maybe
they never played shower with that
simulator
i was so far away from showering with my
parents careful these words i love
that i didn't even know you were
supposed to use soap until i was like
14. i was like wait yeah i'm supposed to
use soap on my body
why there's water it's cleaning me no no
you have to use soap what are you doing
it just never came up because i don't
shower with my
parents yeah and look how i turn out
yeah you know if you feel like a piece
of [ __ ]
i'm not saying these people are but you
know at least you don't shower with your
parents
that's always something i'm just a dodie
mom well that felt good huh
i don't believe i set out to have a
relationship this
close to brittany it's something that
was
plus you know even straight up logic is
all wrong it doesn't even make sense
because if you shower with another
person
one person is always going to be cold
okay i don't know if you showered with
another person before
it sucks one person gets warm other
person get cold than the other person
like can i get warm now oh wait i just
kind of
no no it sucks showering sucks it's a
one-man job and it would always be
after i graduate i'm not moving out
because
i don't have enough time with my mom 24
hours is not long enough
she's gonna move too early
frank who says it's weird sometimes
because we're always together
[Music]
this is another problem when you're too
close to your parents it makes it weird
when you invite other people in i met
frank at church we became best friends
then it developed into a relationship
and we actually got married
i think frank is the only one that has
an issue with us for being so close
i think that's he's the only one in your
life though isn't he
oh god i paused in the way when my mom
got married with him i didn't go to the
wedding
what britney really has an issue with
frank
she doesn't even want him in the house
can we pick me up from the
taylor shop later i guess so i just
don't want to see frank
i just hate him he takes me away from
our shower time
frank comes in between our relationship
a lot because i feel like he's always
like
hey how about me this man yeah because
he's the husband and you're the adult
child and wants to take away my best
friend now
i don't think so
it's this thing where it's like yeah
it's sweet you're close to your mom but
also
no that's oh god you need friends
i mean i don't want to
i'm surprised she did some breastfeeders
still
oh god i bet there's episodes of that i
need you more than anything else
i don't want you to get upset okay just
i'm always in the middle
we've already have a gun
gold cops have guns yeah i see why
people are afraid of cops in america i
get it now
hi baby how are you okay oh a
respectable man with a mustang
good news for you what nothing wrong
with friends i got an 84 on my test
that was my last test okay and now i
just have to look forward to graduation
okay so now you finally can move the
game i'm so excited say it frank
so we're just having a conversation with
your mom
about uh kind of your tomorrow
and i'm curious to know what's your next
step
rent a house
i want to stay with mom a little longer
i mean 19 is usually not that weird to
leave you with your parents right that's
still quite young
she's only 19 by the way um but also
usually people want to move out it's
more like they stay because
they don't have the maybe financials to
move out or a job
because we kind of we kind of wanted you
to to move out
not we you wanted to move out
if i was to rate who comes first
obviously my lord and savior
jesus christ brittany my other two
children
and then frank how about you move out
because you guys are not legally married
oh
the plot thickens they're not legally
married
frank tells everybody we're married
yeah you had the wedding ceremony we saw
photos of it what do you
what was this thing what the [ __ ] was
that name
frank tells you she's got a gun frank
married better do what she says
but we're not legally married on paper i
guess it's sweet and we're not
that weird about nudity with uh your
spouse
either like we do naked saunas together
right yeah i wouldn't be that weird
i don't know it's still weird yeah
i mean the daughter is clearly
psychologically impaired and then
mom is taking care of her and that's
taking some sort of effect
so i don't want to be too judge fully it
is what it is
but uh that's something to witness here
we have a mother
who wakes up 21 year old 21 here there
by
licking her face let's
oh my god they look the same oh boy hey
angelica
yeah mom are you ready to get in i'll be
right there
she's not getting in is she if the water
is still
hot we will share the bath water
separately they share bath water how
could they
why are they sharing bath water they
want each other's germs
we share shower water but we don't share
bath water
yeah we may shower together but we don't
share
bath water
we're not that weird huh yeah these are
weird
isn't there a thing in japan where you
share the bath water
but you shower before you get in the
bath so it's not like you're bringing in
all the dirt it's kind of like sharing a
pool you shower before
i don't know okay so i consider myself
a little bit cleaner but how old is
angelica
too damn old to be doing this too damn
old
i like that the other people in this uh
crazy show
are judging each other i can't believe
they do too
old man i don't think it's a good idea
oh god what the
i'm marcia i'm 68 years young her name
is marcia
marzia your relationship with her is
unique hey puppy
oh she licking her
oh yeah god oh she really goes ham huh
like walk in her room and i just lick
her all up
that's sad if i walk in her room and i
just lick her all
up she's licking her well
you don't lick so you want to wake up
i love it when my mama licks me and it
kind of makes me feel closer to her
because
okay all right i don't i don't pass too
much judgment
all right they're doing their thing and
make them happy
if they like that then i mean that's the
thing
we go to the gynecologist together she's
a reflection of me i'm a reflective of
her if my
kook is disgusting that's her reflection
we're going to vegas
what am i here my my coup
imagine saying that as a guy if my penis
is sideways
my dad is the same it's crazy so
excited and you're sure friends are
gonna be okay
with me of course mom and my bestie all
right i just want to make sure i want
you to i knew she was gonna be
everything to me
i smothered mariah like crazy
i've always been more close to my mom
than my dad i don't know i just
was born that way no you were brought up
that way
the parents make this happen okay let's
get real here
i have different bonds with my girls
what y'all up to
hi baby sometimes we look to chanel
to kind of keep us grounded oh that's
weird
i thought for sure there was only one
daughter there's two
oh imagine being the other daughter
clearly not the favorite
child oh do your makeup wanna wanna do
yours
no i'm good i'm fine go ahead and take a
nap do some homework yeah do that
the things my sister and my mom do i
wouldn't
do the way they dress sometimes is crazy
the way they
act what's up ladies hey even though my
parents are divorced we all live under
one what's up ladies
oh my god why do you always have to have
that face our living situation it's
different
christie and sandra are not married
anymore but it makes sense for us
financially
and it gives me a chance to be around no
he's right he has the right
the tv no you're not what you mean no
you're not
we're in here being in the house again
with three
adult women is more than i bargained for
actually
i've made my mom more comfortable in
being
sexy and embracing her body
but it's cringe though it's i don't know
i guess that's a whole other thing how
you dress or you want to prefer to
address provocatively
i'm not a fan but if people want to do
it good for them i don't care
before we moved back in with my dad me
and my mom used to walk around the house
naked if we wanted to now we can't do
that anymore
because my dad's around yeah stupid dad
add some clothes on
um
[Music]
y'all looking like some ghetto mermaids
or something
[Laughter]
cute y'all a little too much in the
friendly
this is all i hope you know sometimes
showing less is more
right leaves a little bit to the
imagination
huh you don't have to show everything i
mean you you can if you want i'm not
going to stop you
when i get older i'm for sure not
dressing half naked
especially not with my mom i want to pop
out we want to stand out a lot
popping out why you keep you don't want
to show a friend or dad no she ain't
supposed to have that at all what you
doing
i don't want to show down like this i
don't want to show
my dad my niche but i'll walk out like
this in public in front of everyone okay
that makes more sense the dad should
just take the younger sister and leave
i'm not like other moms i'm a cool mom
mean girls yeah that's literally the mom
isn't it oh my god
oh there they are the twin months from
the time she was an
infant i felt that she was going to be
my very best friend
i made her grow up maybe a little
earlier than um
a girl would grow up because i would
talk to her about everything
maybe that's why i named her cher to
share my intimate things with
and i only want to play with her i never
had as much fun playing with other
people
she would wake me up in the morning to
get ready for school and say
you want to play hooky and i'd say yes
and then she would take what's oh it's
when you skip school
we'd go shopping your tour nails you go
to lunch
and then we'd come home and you know my
dad would say so how was school today
and i'd be like
it was great like you know it was good
um but it was our little secret it's our
little special alone time
my mom actually did that with me once we
didn't do the salon
okay but she noticed i didn't want to go
to school one day so she said he won't
skip and i actually really
remember that as a good memory but it
was once
that is very strange we actually feel
for each other
it's like twins hi
i can't tell if it's sweet or or if it's
just super weird
my dad's a doctor my husband's a doctor
she got married at 23. i got married at
22.
cher and i have our own unique handshake
we love to go shopping we love to do
makeup together
it was definitely overwhelming at first
to deal with cher and dawn together
because when they're together especially
in the beginning i feel like i was the
third wheel
yep that'll happen oh she's jan is from
france you're right holy sh
it's still weird kind of sweet but it's
just too much okay yeah that's kind of
how i
feel about that this guy actually get
heart warming i wish i had a close
relationship with my mom
it's like some uncanny valley where it's
like is it too much is it
i don't know so there you have it shower
with mom's simulator
weird or epic uh you decide
i passed on the question to you guys why
don't you guys in the comment tell me
and that's it for this video check out
bass bubble bass
face rgg make your order very epic
and i'll see you guys tomorrow breakfast
we've hosted many celebrations since the
launch of this most relevant of games
we look far and wide to bring you the
most up-to-date and
interesting topics but then there is one
subject
that we somehow missed welcome home my
tuber friends
every home is different and love is
central to every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings
[Music]